welcome to this dw business special
today we're asking what happens if
russia cuts off gas supplies to europe
and there's a good reason to be worried
perhaps the most important piece of gas
infrastructure in europe is being
switched off on july the 11th russia
will turn off the taps of the nordstrom
one pipeline which the country says is
necessary to carry out maintenance
russia says it'll cut off the gas flow
for 10 days but that's happening amid
fears in europe of a winter gas shortage
right now russia holds all the cards
i'm daniel thanks for joining me and
speaking of gas i have two guests who
have fired up to try to chat about this
with me with me in the studio is uh
arthur from our business desk thank you
very much for coming along and also
joining us is uh uh leon is bicky down
the line um he's the man who knows
everything about gas from energy aspects
thank you very much leon as well and
we'll get to you in just a moment um but
first i'll start with you arthur and you
can tell it's serious because i've
rolled up my sleeves um what is it like
for you in this situation um we're
having these these energy supply
shortages prices are going up um for
energy are you taking uh shorter colder
showers because of it well i'm not sure
i should divulge too much about my
bathing habits please spare us but um
that's an interesting point here is
because i think one of the things about
this situation is that we are hearing
talk of a gas crisis an energy crisis
yet a lot of us haven't necessarily seen
that yet in our daily lives perhaps in
recent weeks we've seen energy bills
slowly increasing further increases down
the line but it's an important message
that individual behavior is going to be
very very important in terms of how we
ultimately conserve gas and conserve
energy it is one of the ways that has
been consistently highlighted by
politicians to to alleviate this crisis
you know that we need to have like you
said shorter showers colder showers save
where we can so perhaps it's one of the
areas where we will get over this is
through public awareness campaigns to
get people to change their everything's
gonna have to do that bit but also big
industry uh the industries as well you
know even in the summer time they're
using a lot of gas for producing likes
of gas bottles and and gas bottles uh
glass bottles is what i wanted to say um
and all kinds of uh important industrial
production but leon let's turn to you
now have you noticed the impact of the
energy problems in your day-to-day life
i suppose in
rising prices for all kinds of goods
right
yeah absolutely i think it feeds into
into everything that we're seeing when
it comes to the products that we're
buying at the supermarket for example
just requiring higher input prices
ultimately gas is used in order to
produce fertilizers so that's why we are
seeing a lot of those food prices
actually shooting up but i mean more
generally speaking a lot of households
in the uk are encountering rising
terrorists putting around five to six
million households alone uh into energy
poverty since the latest raytag in uh in
april
okay well let's hear now from germany's
economy minister and we'll get back to
you in a second leon
he's also the vice chancellor and he
says he doubts russia's explanation for
the cut in gas supplies let's take a
listen
we need to be honest and say that it's
impossible to rule out a further gas
supply cut
we saw it with the reduction of north
stream one the technical reasons were
given as a pretext and since it happened
once it can obviously happen again
that's an open secret and in a situation
like this one nothing can be ruled out
german economy minister and vice
chancellor robert harbeck there unable
to rule out further reductions of gas
flow um leon returning to you is
russia's explanation for halting supply
due to maintenance credible
well i think uh the the previous
statements that robert harvick in
particular has issued surrounding the
the fact that this doesn't quite add up
are actually
have a lot of merit really you're
looking at
russia and gazpro in particular citing
the lack or missing gas turbine that is
currently being overhauled in canada is
one of the reasons why there is this
flow constraint on north stream one but
according to havoc this is actually just
part of a normal cycle whereby
this gas turbine or these gas turbines
are overhauled on an annual basis where
the freshly overhauled gas turbine is
being re-imported into russia in
exchange for another gas turbine so this
just takes place cyclically on an annual
basis and this gas turbine that is
currently
definitively stuck in canada because of
the because of the sanctions regime was
not actually scheduled to get back to
russia until fall of this year anyways
so why exactly
nordstrom one flows have to be curtailed
over summer is a bit unclear at this
stage
so um quite suspect on the on the timing
at least um arthur tell us more about
this nordstrom one pipeline we've heard
a lot about it recently we've heard
about the
um the building of the north stream ii
as well they wanted to expand those gas
deliveries from germany from russia into
germany
how important
is this supply route for gas to europe
well it's the most important supply
route so i mean we we've heard so much
in recent months about how much russian
gas has been coming into the eu over
recent years around 40 last year and
then in certain countries it's more so
germany took in more than 50 of of um
its natural gas from russia last year
and north stream one is the most
important pipeline i mean the
comfortable majority of germany's gas
comes via north stream one and you know
not far off half of all europe's comes
from north street one so it's a crucial
archery so and when we look at the
overall relationship that russian gas
has had with europe fundamental to it is
this nordstrom one pipeline which has
only been there for 11 years but it's in
those 11 years in which russian gas
supply to europe and to germany in
particular has really accelerated and
gone up year on year up until this
current crisis yes and we can see it on
screen now the north stream one and the
north stream two pipeline which was um
built but uh didn't actually come online
due to the war in ukraine and the yamal
pipeline as well which runs
through ukraine into germany
um let's
move on now to the the seriousness of
this situation
heading into the winter time as well
it's worth noting that the eu is rushing
to fill its underground tanks its gas
storage tanks
ahead of the winter and that's become
even more urgent now just looking at the
state of those reserves at the moment
the eu stocks were filled to just 77 of
capacity in october last year and were
drawn down to 25 by the end of winter in
march
now the eu is trying again to refill its
gas storage sites late last month they
were up to about 56 percent full but now
a new regulation says they must be
filled to at least 80 percent of their
capacity by november now if russia
wanted to squeeze europe preventing that
could be a key method to keeping the
upper hand leon how critical is it that
the eu fills its gas tanks now as
opposed to finding new forms of supply
for the winter
well i think it's it's
there's always a risk on the supply side
that
something might break that you're
looking at for example less lng imports
into the european market
than we currently expect if there is a
colder winter in uh in asia you're
looking at the risk surrounding you know
pipeline outages when it comes to
norwegian supply so if you really want
to make sure that you have adequate
supply over winter to just also
guarantee uh supply to to protected end
consumers such as households and
critical infrastructure you need those
storage tanks to be relatively full in
order to also cope with a scenario in
which temperatures across europe are you
know potentially also colder than uh
than usual
okay i just want to touch on that um
once more because you mentioned the lng
um uh capacity being booked up from asia
that was before the war in ukraine also
last winter it was very expensive for
europeans to get their gas supply so how
much of the new recent price rises are
caused by existing issues that already
existed and how much is caused by the
acute situation of the war in ukraine
i think we're we're looking at a
situation in which the the tightness
that we are seeing on the market has
really been there since 2021 where we
have seen a resurgence in demand where
we're also in a situation in which for
example asia was actually drawing a lot
of lng where europe was actually using
up a lot of gas in the previous winter
because it was uh relatively cold in
april and may so this contributed to
this tightness into the low end october
storage fills that we were seeing in in
2021 and
these fears of
low supply are really or were
exacerbated by the conflict in ukraine
and most recently by the politicization
of gas flows from russia into europe and
into germany in particular via north
stream one so really this is this has
been a long long time in the making it's
a confluence of factors but for now the
primary driver for the market when we're
also looking at prices being at around
180 euros a megawatt hour on the ttf for
the for the front month this is really
primarily a risk premium caused by this
by these fears surrounding nordstrom 1.
so it certainly made a bad situation a
lot worse um arthur focusing um on this
energy transition so germany announced
what it called the energy vendor a long
time ago in order to transition germany
to renewable sources of energy however a
lot of the focus on changing these
sources of energy was put on electricity
supply specifically so we're talking
about uh wind we're talking about solar
um
how has the country fallen behind so far
when it comes to
gas or let's say heating energy
diversification because a lot of the
effort was focused on electricity you
can make heat with electricity but we're
still having to take a lot of gas from
russia how have we gotten to this
position well if you think about that
energy vendor that you talked about a
major fork in the road for that was the
fukushima nuclear disaster when germany
took the dramatic decision which was
applauded at the time that um chancellor
merkel took to close down germany's
nuclear plants which are now in the
process of being closed this year the
final three closed by the end of the
year however the big mistake the big
strategic mistake germany made at that
time which was warned about
significantly at the time of the us and
others was that they were relying too
much on russian gas for that transition
the transition away from nuclear and
also the transition towards renewables
and we have to remember this is a
warning that had been made for decades
american governments in the 1980s ronald
reagan's government warning germany and
the europe do not be too reliant on
russian gas trump
exactly he was criticized for it but at
least on that one narrow point he was
right i suppose and well yes and what we
also have to remember is this is not a
sort of turning point which was reached
a while ago up until the start of this
year nordstrom 2 was going to be
potentially opened this year and there
would be a huge increase in that gas
capacity so this is a major strategic
mistake that germany made it relied much
too heavily on russia as a long-term gas
partner there's a relationship going
back 50 years but it's we've seen and it
as i said it's been warned about it's a
major major miscalculation those
including states in central and eastern
europe who warned russia would not be a
reliable partner they would use germany
and europe's reliance on russian gas as
a way of of avoiding transit fees to
those countries through nordstrom 1 and
then north stream 2 that the price would
have to be paid unfortunately we are all
potentially paying this price now yeah
it seems that germany may have learned
its lesson but too late of course we're
currently stuck in this crisis as it is
um well finding substitutes for russian
gas has become a top priority for
western europe so far with some
success last month u.s supplies of
liquefied natural gas surpassed russian
pipeline gas for the first time ever
while other gas producers will be
selling more to europe including norway
the uk algeria and qatar
still this won't be enough to completely
replace russian supplies right away
um
arthur i i have a simple direct question
but it might be a complicated answer
sorry about that but um can the eu live
without russian energy well listen
daniel the thing is spring will come
next year no matter what so life goes on
let's hope so but the perfect yeah well
who knows i suppose given recent recent
months but um you know the fact is at
what cost at what cost will come through
this it depends who you ask if you talk
to certain german businesses for example
in the chemical sector where there's 350
000 jobs talk about the metal sector
they will say that their businesses are
not going to survive a total shutdown in
russian gas they're too dependent on
gas-fired power plants they will have to
make significant closures layoffs major
production cuts so for those businesses
their weight may not be necessarily
surviving for some of them then you've
the question of citizens for example if
germany ultimately if if russia does no
longer provide gas as some are
predicting after this maintenance work
is finished well then there will always
be the question of where will the gas
come from
germany may then activate its emergency
third part of its of its um plan for for
that scenario that could lead to major
fuel poverty could lead to blackouts it
could lead to periods where the most
vulnerable in society may not have
enough fuel to heat their homes or at
least rationing from industry so that
people can have heating for their homes
at a
bearable price perhaps
but then of course it has impact on
industry which could then drive up
prices elsewhere so knock on effect
exactly so no matter what there's a
major major price that people are going
to have to pay for this so in the longer
term can europe live without russian gas
certainly of course there are options
and we're seeing that all happening
whether it's lng whether it's renewables
but in the short term a major price is
going to have to be paid and we've
already started paying it
okay um
so leon i guess that then begs the
question how likely it is that the eu
can even do what it's set out to do
with its targets to get rid of russian
energy sources entirely of course
eventually it'll be possible but can it
do it sooner rather than later what do
you think is is feasible
well i mean we are we're already in a
situation right now where
because europe has
set
global gas prices over the last couple
of months at a very very high level
we are already
essentially working through all of the
flexibilities that we still have in the
global gas balance we are looking at
maximum production from norway into
europe we are looking at maximum
algerian flows uh flows from azerbaijan
and lng flows as well so the question is
just in the short term how much more
flexibility do we actually have compared
to what we are seeing right now and the
answer to that simply is not a lot we
are going to see slightly more lng
availability probably over the course of
next year but we are also looking at a
situation which for example china might
actually start to take a bit more than
lng if its economy recovers from covert
related lockdowns
so all of this means that in the short
term we still need gas from russia to
actually balance the market in order to
avoid such scenarios as widespread
rationing for example of industry
okay so it's it's not good news but uh
at least you've given us the truth like
any good doctor it's tough news but we
need to hear it um but thank you very
much and sadly that brings us to the end
of uh this dw business special um but
i'd like to remind you at home remember
to watch our series business beyond and
check out the link where my friend and
colleague rob explains why prices are
rocketing worldwide
so yeah thanks a lot to my guests
leon izbiki from energy aspects and
arthur sullivan as well in the studio
thank you very much for coming in if
you've enjoyed this video slap that like
button and subscribe and from me and the
business team in berlin goodbye and
thanks for watching
you